welcome to another thankful Thursday I
believe is important to thank the people
in your life have had an impact on you
and your business and spread some good
karma in the world recognize somebody
today and say thank you so today I want
to thank my programmer a deal now deals
been working with me for just over a
year and we recently completed a project
that I'm really excited about called the
believer Graham the believer Graham is a
video project where you can send a
customized video to a friend of yours
who needs a little bit of encouragement
who needs a little bit of support who
needs a little bit of love it's
something that I'm super proud of and if
you haven't checked it out yet it's free
and you should hint hint wink wink now
deal was a man behind the scenes working
his coding magic to make it all happen
there are a lot of late nights a lot of
sleepless nights a lot of emails from me
saying can we make just one more tweaked
and then we finally got it up and the
results so far have been amazing these
videos are really encouraging a lot of
people to continue to believe in
themselves but we had one little problem
you see we allow you to upload a picture
if you want to included in the video and
what we found was if two people uploaded
a picture with the exact same filename
it would erase the first person's
picture it resulted in people getting
videos with somebody else's picture in
it as soon as we noticed it it was the
middle of the night and a deal set to
work on finding a solution not only did
he fix it immediately but he also wrote
to me saying I'd like to write to
everybody personally to apologize and
ask them if they could send a new
picture and i'll happily make it for
them now the thing with the deal is he's
always been a behind-the-scenes guy he's
never been customer-facing he's never
been talking to any of the people who
are involved in the community he's
always been our programmer and I have
people on my team who could do that who
would reach out whose job it is to talk
to those people but a deal stepped up
and volunteered to do it and wanted to
do it and that's what you want for your
team that's why I'm so grateful for
everybody on my team with people like a
deal because they don't just do what you
tell them to do they don't just do their
job description they're emotionally
invested in what we're doing and they
want to see it succeed so they'll do
what
it takes to make it happen so deal thank
you so much for all your hard work and
dedication on that project I really
really really appreciate it and for
those are you watching take some time
today to thank somebody in your life or
in your business sometimes that an
impact who's helped you grow who's
helped giving you encouragement make a
video send an email write a note pick
them out the coffee just say thank you
it'll make them feel great it'll make
you feel great and you'll be spreading
positive karma out there in the world
and believe thank you guys so much for
watching you like the video you want to
see more you can subscribe to the
channel I'll see you soon oh and if you
want to give somebody a public shout-out
leave it in the comments below tell
somebody publicly how much you love them
even your new leader isn't told me not
to quit I look for to them every week
they have changed my life thank you
you